hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my legends of tomorrow
episode 1 video the first two episodes
are kind of a two-parter but they're
airing them week to week so next week
will be part 2 just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway it's it meas DC week
so of course I'm going to do a couple
giveaways all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so because this is
such a huge deal I'm just going to do a
top 10 WTF instead of my normal top 5
starting with number 10 Vandal Savage
has conquered the earth and we don't
even know how he's come back yet as rip
hunter explains unless Hawkman or
Hawkgirl delivers the death blow to
Vandal Savage he can be regenerated from
a single cell so I'm assuming at the end
of arrow episode 8 during the big flash
arrow crossover when they killed him
Merlyn scooped his ashes up he was able
to regenerate from one of those ashes I
don't know if that happened on its own I
don't know if they're going to show that
in a scene it actually be pretty cool
but we also learned number 9 WTF that
Vandal Savage kills rip hunters son in
that first episode so after all the
terrible things the Vandal Savage is
done that's the straw that broke the
camel's back where rip hunters like I'm
calling this isn't happening
anymore I have to fix this so he breaks
from the time masters I know it sounds
very familiar very Doctor Who type plot
line where the doctor rebels against the
Time Lords rip hunter rebels against the
time masters they're going to be a whole
lot of doctor who jokes this season but
on a number 7 WTF as you'd expect the
time masters only care about preserving
the timeline not about preserving
humanity I'm assuming they would extend
that courtesy to any other group in the
universe now they haven't really
addressed the multiverse on legends of
tomorrow yet but because it's so far
into the future they're probably going
to know about it
when the Time Master said you know what
if in stopping Vandal Savage we leave
the earth vulnerable to an even bigger
villain who did you guys think of I just
I immediately shot to Darkseid what
villain is bigger than Darkseid the
forces of apocalypse you know other than
maybe the cosmic entity death on a my
number 6 WTF so rip hunter goes around
collecting all these people we get beats
with each of the characters where
they're at in the world at this moment
Rey is working with arrow trying to do
hive stuff as part of like arrows
ongoing season 4 plot Captain Cold
heatwave stealing minivans from young
father's in the middle of the night the
canary in Beirut in a very raiders of
the archetype bar when he takes them to
that rooftop scene and
I know it looks familiar from the
trailer that they aired Wei Wei long
time ago at the beginning of the year
but that was actually a promo that they
had the flash and arrow in like Oliver
and Barry that was only for the purposes
of selling the show they just they they
put their big characters in there so
people would get excited they explained
that now that they don't need them now
the show's already a big deal like the
network's really really love it they
already picked it up for a full season
they don't need flash and arrow as much
I mean we got Oliver in the episode but
they basically reshot that whole scene
with just the team that rip hunter is
assembling but really the emotional
through line for me begins with number 5
WTF
Ray Palmer wants his life to mean
something like he has that speech with
Oliver I died and nothing happened I'm a
billionaire look at all the crazy stuff
I've accomplished and nobody cared
nobody noticed so I have a chance to
save the world I'm going to take it it's
kind of the same deal with all the other
characters they have like their own
funny versions of that conversation
where it's like dude I got to do this or
or in the case of pairings where one of
them is reluctant the other one's like
dude we got to do this like Hawkman and
Hawkgirl
hey let's duke this out weiner gets to
decide what we do there's a certain
purity to Hawkman and Hawkgirl like
fighting to solve their disputes winner
gets to decide and it's absolute like
they're totally pure about it like you
don't see Hawkgirl being bitter about
losing like I can't believe I lost I
didn't want to come she completely
accepts it it's the Warriors code and it
seems like as of right now like in the
timeline I'm assuming it's present-day
just assume this is happening in real
time with arrow and flash she still
doesn't remember everything so she's
probably just gonna learn new things
like she met her son during the episode
she's probably going to continue to
remember things through the season Sarah
on the other side of that coin too is
also still experiencing bloodlust
it's the show's way of acknowledging all
the stuff that happened to the
characters in the past year like they
went through some crazy stuff and
they're not just going to completely
wipe the slate clean just because they
started a new TV show favorite funny
moment right before they got on the ship
is probably Martin Stein drugging Jack's
Jackson though just knocking him out
just like okay so you don't want to go I
totally respect that
here let's toast to the future boom down
for the count I like that bit of
Darkness in Stein in the fact that he
just kind of brushes Ray Palmer off yeah
you were my student night I don't
remember you at all but also in the
comics Ray Palmer is a professor at Ivy
University Ronnie Raymond the you know
Ron
Raymond from firestorm is one of his
students on the number four WTF meet the
Waverider and Gideon is the computer the
same Gideon it sounds like that the
reverse-flash is using this is also
really awesome wrinkle like the Gideon
stuff is like its own separate thing we
have to talk about the Waverider though
obviously named after the Waverider
character from the comics also a time
traveler the origin story for the
Waverider character sounds mysteriously
like the plot of legends of tomorrow so
in the far future a character named
Matthew Ryder who's a scientist wants to
stop this big dictator that's taken over
named the monarch so he builds a
Timeship goes back in time and tries to
find monarch as a child so he can end
his reign of terror before it ever
starts so that's kind of like what's
going on with Vandal Savage and rip
hunter so you can see how they're
honoring the comics in that way the
later DC change wave riders backstory
and made him a version of Booster Gold
Booster Gold ended up becoming wave
rider if you want to read the story of
rip hunter turning Booster Gold into
wave rider that was during convergence
his powers are actually pretty cool he
can just like he can touch you he can
see your timeline just by making
physical contact with you there's a
whole bunch of other stuff he can do but
just think of his powers as being like
the Timeship with the addition of Gideon
Gideon though let's talk about Gideon
so during flash season one Morena
Baccarin who's also on Gotham on a ton
other shows she's in the Deadpool movie
too she was the voice of the Gideon
computer that the reverse-flash was
using but season two and on legends of
tomorrow it's a different actress doing
the voice I haven't been able to find
out who the actresses but if I learn
before next week's video I'll just I'll
mention it in my next legends of
tomorrow video for those of you asking
the reverse-flash is coming back to the
flash next week the ego Bart dawn
reverse-flash at the end of last week's
episode he pulls Gideon out and it's
like where the hell am I get in but you
know what time period am I in we don't
know if Gideon is a singular entity that
just you know transfers its matrix
between places or if Gideon is like a
mass produced type of computer I'm
guessing it's like a special thing in
eobard thawne in season one said that he
was from about a hundred and fifty years
in the future which is about the time
Vandal Savage has conquered the earth so
I'm wondering how they're going to weave
those two plot points together it's hard
enough explaining continuity between
shows and modern day but when you add
time
travel into it like changing the
timeline it gets really complicated so
we'll have to wait till next week's
episode of the flash to see you know
where you Bart Don is from in the future
and if the same thing that's going on
religion to tomorrow with Vandal Savage
is also affecting his timeline on to my
number three WTF Hawkman and Hawkgirl
meet their son who he says was born from
around World War one when their names
were Boardman he's professor Boardman
st. Roch's is actually one of the home
cities of Hawkman and Hawkgirl in the
comics so you get this really touching
family moment you know like part of the
emotional through line of the episode
where Hawkgirl just like some things
click in her brain and she's like okay I
understand now and he actually he ends
up giving her the medallion at the end
of the episode my mother gave this to me
so I kind of like the way they dealt
with this where the professor is a
rational person he's like you told me
that this might happen I might run into
you in the future you died when I was
about 10 years old they didn't make it
too wishy-washy like they completely
dealt with it in that first episode I
mean I mean Hawkgirl is still going to
be remembering things from her past in
the next couple of episodes they'll
still talk about their son a little bit
but now in her mind she is more fully
that Hawkgirl character I really like
all the Hawkman Hawkgirl scenes in this
episode I like the pair together the
actors that play Hawkman and Hawkgirl
I feel Hawkman is slowly growing on me I
feel like some of his dialogue sticks in
his mouth like they they reduced the
amount of dialogue he has just because
it doesn't sound quite as good coming
out of him so looking forward to more
Hawkman smashing things just as long as
they avoid really long Hawkman speeches
I feel like they'll be fine thankfully
they also addressed the self-fulfilling
prophecy where it's like our son is
going to die in 24 hours we have to take
him with us so naturally you're trying
to change the timeline brings about the
very event that you are trying to avoid
so it's like the idea of a fixed point
in time something that you can't change
and actually and they addressed it in
season one of the flash where Barry goes
back in time the first time the reverse
flash actually you Bart Thawne tells him
if you try to change something to avoid
a really bad event time will find a way
to replace that with something equally
bad if not worse so one of my number two
WTF something equally worse comes along
Chronos Boba Fett however you want to
think about him Darth Vader I know there
was some confusion when he showed up the
first time in that parking lot that was
in present day a lot of people were like
hey wait if there are nine
seventy-five then how did those dudes
know about Darth Vader because that
movie didn't come out till 77 no the
dudes when they made the Darth Vader
reference they were still in present-day
Kronos in the comics is actually in Adam
Ville and he's still a time traveler his
costume looks like this so you know very
different they changed the character a
little bit but he's more of a silly
time-traveling villain rather than the
more badass bounty hunter that the TV
shows portraying who was actually turns
out working for the time masters trying
to track down rip hunter and bring him
back which is where we get to our number
one WTF rip hunter lied to them all he
picked them because their lives means
zero to the timeline they are the
opposite of Legends that's where the
show stops being like a Justice Society
type team-up or Justice League team up
and becomes more of a Suicide Squad
situation people with a particular set
of skills that nobody else gives a damn
about although that's not technically
true they all have their friends but
time itself does not give a damn about
them so they are expendable if they die
in this mission it won't matter it won't
make a bit of difference like I said
though this is just the first part of a
two-part episode it's just they're
calling it like a two-hour pilot that is
just airing in two different parts
so they'll finish this initial storyline
next week they'll probably deal with the
Chronos character there are a bunch of
big DC characters that are showing up in
future episodes like Jonah Hex is the
biggest one they just announced he's
going to show up when they go back into
the Wild West so they'll be jumping
around in time seeing really interesting
characters from DC's history from the
past and from the future
and yes Constantine can totally come on
season two if they green-lighted for
season two which they haven't done yet
they they're only doing 16 episodes
they've shot about 11 of them so far so
I think once they get towards the end
they'll probably start talking about
season 2 whether it's going to happen
whether it's not going to happen if
they're going to change things
but let me know what's your favorite
thing about the episode and where do you
want to see them go next now keep in
mind there's 16 episodes so they're
going to be going to a lot of different
places we'll get to see connor hawke all
kinds of awesome stuff congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner Louis
John you win the reverse flash ring from
the the last couple of videos that I've
been doing just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I get your contact info
announce the next winner whenever I post
my next DC video so I'll be doing like
some Suicide Squad Justice League Wonder
Woman like DC movie related videos to
over the weekend you may
you see me posting about it on Twitter
this morning but they just revealed what
vixens costume is going to look like on
arrow it totally looks like it does in
the comics
if you don't know she had an animated
series there was the option for it to go
to live-action or her to go on arrow or
legends of tomorrow they decided to
bring her on arrow and I think it's
going to be episode 15 so it should be
in a couple weeks it'll be a lot of fun
but they are doing a season two of the
cartoon series I'll talk more about it
whenever we get to that vixen episode on
arrow in a couple weeks there's a whole
bunch of awesome stuff happening but a
couple my friends are working on a show
called Beowulf so that has absolutely
nothing to do with DC Comics so I'm
going to do a separate video for that so
that should post in the next day or two
just explaining what's going on it'll be
a Saturday show so we'll worry about
that on Saturday so a whole bunch of
stuff going on it's going to be really
fun trying to do Easter eggs for all
these episodes just because there's so
much stuff packed in but while you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for the Suicide Squad trailer
video and the Wonder Woman trail that I
just posted and you can click here for
this week's flash and arrow episodes
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight